(playful music)
- [Voiceover] Was our
first feature Point Break?
Did we do that before Tremors?
- [Voiceover] No, not officially yet.
- [Voiceover] Right.
So as a company, Tremors would be the first,
technically the first feature.
- Yeah, I guess.
I don't know.
Someone should Google that.
(playful music)
(clears throat)
- [Voiceover] Are you
gonna ask us questions,
or do you want us to start talking?
- [Voiceover] Could you
introduce each other?
- I would love to.
- I would like to introduce
you to Tom Woodruff, Jr.,
who's the co-founder of
Amalgamated Dynamics.
- I'd like to introduce
you to Alec Gillis.
He's the co-founder of ADI,
home of the Oscar-winning
creature effects team.
- [Voiceover] When people
think of practical effects,
creatures, you think of
non-computer generated characters.
We've been lucky to be involved
with some of the biggest
and best of those types of monsters.
We did the worms in Tremors --
- [Voiceover] We did the fat makeups
on Tim Allen in the Santa Clause --
- [Voiceover] All the
practical animals in Jumanji --
- [Voiceover] We've done the Alien,
we've done the Predator --
- [Voiceover] Starship Troopers.
- I wasn't done.
- Well, you can keep goin', buddy.
- Of course, there's always the gorilla.
Cut, right, now, that's perfect.
Now we cut to putting the gorilla costume.
(hip hop music)
We started performing our own creatures,
because we both had
this sort of observation
of stunt men, despite their
talents and their skills.
Them going into a creature
suit, and not really knowing
how to make a creature suit work.
- It would be very weird
for us to just say,
we're gonna build
something, and then bring
it to set, and say, "Now what?"
Are you hungry?
You want some food?
If you're a digital animator,
you build the character,
and you follow through,
and you make it move,
and you bring it to life,
so that's our philosophy.
The final step is performance,
'cause that's where it lives.
You want to try a little tiny piece?
Here.
Go ahead.
What do you think?
You want some more.
You, hey, hey!
He's, listen, listen!
I can get you fresh bread.
Tremors is an example of a film
that was from the pre-digital era.
If you look at it, the practical effects,
they've stood the test of
time, and we're proud of that.
- Digital effects can do things
that we can't possibly do.
Practical effects have a presence to them,
that even the best CGI work gets close to,
but doesn't completely achieve.
In other words, there's
more emotion, I believe,
to a practical creature,
than to a digital creature.
- Wave to the camera, and say good-bye.
Bye bye.
Bye.
(sighs)
He's so temperamental.